[Music]
peace be with you welcome to the Dean
comedy our hosts this week on the Dean
show we're going to be talking about the
chatter Nova shootings and the Charlton
Charleston shootings we're going to be
talking about all of this and much much
more
with Professor from the Arizona
University who is a sociologist expert
political science expert we got an
expert on the Dean show to shed some
light on many of the sad situations that
are happening on the ground here and all
over America with my next guest don't go
anywhere we have a lot to talk about a
great an exciting program full of great
information you don't want to miss out
we'll be right back peace
[Music]
[Music]
this is the welcome back to the Dean
show and our special guest professor
from the Arizona University professor
Musa how are you thank you very much for
being on a Dean show can you tell our
viewing audience because it's your first
time in the program a little bit about
yourself professor
absolutely so I'm a I'm the managing
editor for the Southwest initiative for
the study of Middle East conflicts also
known as sis net based out of the
University of Arizona and I'm a
cognitive sociologist by by a trade but
I focus a lot on the Middle East and
terrorism as well as sort of related to
that so this is really your expertise
sociology people and politics political
sciences you're the right person for the
job an expert in this area you had
really sad situations occurring you had
the Charleston shooting recently it's
already kind of fading in the news and
now recently the Chattanooga shootings
that have happened and one is considered
kind of like a lone wolf on the other
spectrum you have a whole religion but
being blamed for this situation what are
your thoughts on that yeah so there's
there's sort of two trends to take note
of so the first one is that in case of
Dylan roof in Charleston as you pointed
out when he committed his crime they
immediately tried to portray him as a
lone wolf and often they also try to
portray white terrorists as mentally ill
and in the case of Chattanooga so in
case of roof the FBI has said they can't
they won't even consider that terror
look the FBI headset is that they're not
considering that kurz and even though it
was clearly a politically motivated
attack on you know with it meets the
FBI's definition of terrorism for Batum
but they're not going to call it
terrorism and in case of Chattanooga the
FBI said that they're going to consider
it terrorism until it's proven other
that it's not so the starting premise
when an Arab or Muslim commits a crime
is that it's terrorism and the starting
premise when the white person commits a
crime is that it's not terrorism so
that's important and then the the issue
of mental illness there's also a big
difference so again a white terrorist
like Joseph Andrew stack or Dylan roof
or any of these guys are immediately
considered to be crazy they talk about
all they're depressed they're bipolar
they went through a divorce you know
whatever and the case of the Chattanooga
shooter his diagnosed as being bipolar
in the case of Nidal Malik Hasan the
Fort Hood shooter he he had spot
treatment for his own mental issues
because they were going to send him to
Afghanistan he was a conscientious
objector he tried very hard to the
process that to get out and being sent
to Afghanistan he talked to people about
his about his sort of struggles with
this and with the fact that he was being
sort of discriminated against in the
army people were using racial slurs and
stuff against him and he talked to
counselors and he sought treatment and
tried to go through the legal process to
get out of his statement but there was
no exit for him and he snapped and he
went on a shooting rampage but but his
mental illness was never considered it
was not even up for for discussion so on
so in virtue of being a Muslim basically
you can't be mentally ill you're a cold
calculating criminal mastermind whereas
if you're a white person commits the
terrorist act you're definitely crazy so
that's you know those are some of the
opening Sperrys
you had someone who was kind of
forgotten he's back up in the news but
not too long ago James Holmes he was the
Dark Knight movie Massacre he killed 14
people and he was actually a Christian
not to disparage on any Christians but
he was someone who was part of the
Presbyterian Church and again they
looked at his mental illness he wasn't
someone now if imagine if he was a
Muslim and then you have the Robert Doug
eart who was was a Christian and he was
putting together to a plan to Massacre
an entire community and this didn't get
in a wall-to-wall media coverage yeah
Robert yeah kazusa
so he's a Christian minister and I
failed congressional candidate his plan
was to quote utterly destroy a
predominantly Muslim suburb in upstate
New York and the campaign was going to
include bombing a school and a mosque
and then going on a shooting rampage to
kill as many people as they could and it
wasn't just him he got nine other people
that agreed to join this spot but this
is Crusade and the astonishing thing is
so he was hot in the middle of this of
carrying out the spot he had acquired
weapons to do it he had made as I said
contacts with co-conspirators they were
it wasn't an imminent terror plot that
was spoiled so when a Muslim commits is
intercepted in the middle of an imminent
terrorist but they're usually sentenced
to life in prison mr. Duggar was he was
sentenced to home detention
he lost his gun permit and he was fined
$30,000 that's it that's it and his
co-conspirators my knowledge worked
hardest for anything at all and then
more recently there's been a lot of
protests from Muslim groups in civil
rights groups and so now he's facing
some additional civil rights charges but
in terms of his of his sort of criminal
liability he got you know
a very short home detention thing and
I'm fine whereas a Muslim who was
intercepted committing anything near
that same skill would have been
sentenced to life in prison generally
and the worst part is when Muslim a lot
of times Muslims were intercepted in
these plots the FBI you know the FBI is
has people and a lot of Muslim
communities to kind of keep an eye on
Muslims to make sure they're not getting
radicalized and if they think that
someone might be prone to radicalization
a lot of times they basically entrap
them they in some of these cases where
people have been foiled and accused of
trying to carry out a plot it was the
FBI will help suggest the plot it was
the FBI who helped you know provide them
with fake weapons and fake you know
passports and stuff just to get them to
say that they'll do this thing and then
they get arrested but no one was ever in
any imminent danger it's just that in
virtue of seeming sympathetic or willing
to carry out an attack like this you get
life in prison if you're a Muslim but if
you're someone like mr. Duggar who's
gonna actually came up on his own
initiative and formed the whole
coalition to carry out a massacre you
know you get you get a fine you get
house arrest a big problem why is it
that most Americans they've never heard
of Robert Duggar he's not a household
name he's not getting the kind of press
the wall-to-wall media coverage that
many of these other people as long as as
soon as you're connected with anything
of Islam you're all over the press but
in this case no it's huge disparities in
media coverage as well so consider for
instance a good good sort of
side-by-side comparison would be to
consider Joseph andrew stack the third
he was this white guy who was
anti-government anti the IRS he hid a
suicide bombing on on the IRS esalaam
complex in Austin Texas
he killed the federal agent
millions of dollars in damage and he he
was hoping to kill hundreds because
there's hundreds people that work there
they were just arriving for the day but
for the grace of God he would have
killed hundreds especially if there was
bigger structural damage to the building
which he intended on his manifesto so he
commits the suicide bombing that kills a
federal agent right now compare that to
Abu Farouk Abdulmutallab this Somali
can't be tried to commit a suicide
bombing via he was an he was called the
Christmas Day bomber but he had an
underwear bomb that failed so he didn't
kill anyone you didn't hurt anyone he
didn't even really damage the plane
except for mild cosmetic damage the only
person who was hurt with him but as a
result of Abdulmutallab they had they
put in body scanners and all of it and a
lot of these airports you know it was
wall-to-wall coverage about it for you
know weeks and weeks and weeks
Joseph Andrew sac killed someone caused
millions of dollars in damage nearly
killed hundreds and the FBI just said
he's just a crazy guy lone wolf even
though he clearly belongs to a an
ideology that's fairly widespread and
you know the media was basically over it
the next day as soon as the I said it's
not terrorism it's just a lone wolf that
was it there was no commemoration for
the federal agent who died there was no
you know no big policy changes to
prevent something like this from
happening again
in fact because the government refused
to do any kind of policy change to
prevent ideologues like mr. stack from
carrying out more attacks the IRS
decided that they were going to
investigate these kinds of right-wing
ideologues in the hopes of breaking up
some of these groups so they don't get
attacked because there's a target of a
lot of right-wing attacks and as a
result of that of their probe into
right-wing groups one that became public
Republican lawmakers started a wish on
against the IRS and so the FBI is
investigating the IRS now for for having
investigated
right-wing groups rather than
investigating the terrorists who
committed the crime and people who are
sympathetic to that terrorist they're
investigating the IRS for investigating
the crime I mean it's it's insane
it's really insane indeed what it is
insane we have a lot more questions to
ask professor Musa here at a Dean show
Moses by the way professor Moses with us
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
please subscribe to the DCO follow us on
our official Facebook and Twitter pages
in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below
[Music]
back here on the Deshawn I hope you're
benefiting I truly am some amazing facts
brought to your attention that are out
there if you want to indeed it's insane
the contradictions the hypocrisy and
wall-to-wall media coverage for a Muslim
he's a lone wolf but they make them out
to be like a representative of Islam
which we know Islam is free and clear of
a lot of these extremists and you have
also written an article exposing many of
the other people who are doing heinous
crimes getting no wall-to-wall media
coverage 60,000 plus people have been
killed majority of innocent people many
also American five six thousand plus
decapitation training of young kids to
commit their hideous terroristic crimes
in this article talking about the cartel
can you discuss this with our audience
thank you yeah absolutely so what's
astonishing is that any literally
anything that people are upset about
that Isis says the Mexican drug cartels
do as well and on a bigger scale so if
you're upset about enslaving women the
Mexican drug cartels enslave far more
women than Isis if you're excited about
beheadings the Mexican drug cartels
behead far more people than Isis if
you're upset about you know just the
sheer number of death and destruction
the cartels killed more people than Isis
and they kill them in horrific ways
often you know mutilating their bodies
and I mean people were were concerned
about Isis having will burn the guy to
death
the cartels do that they burn people to
death but they've also cut off someone's
face and sewed it to a soccer ball
they actually cooked an American killed
and cooked an American and eat him and
that was not a news item they cooked an
American they ate this American this
group they ate him yes
I mean so there's there's widespread
newts news coverage actually about a
year ago when one of the nusrah people
one of the sort of fighters in Syria ate
someone's heart and that was a huge deal
right they were talking about it all the
time all these like jihadi cannibals out
there in Syria but there was nothing
well it but that that wasn't even an
American but somehow the American news
media doesn't care when an American gets
killed cooked and eaten and and in fact
even in terms of American deaths right
more than 300 people Americans were
killed in just a few years on the
Mexican side of the border and on the US
side of the border the drug cartels
controlled the overwhelming majority of
the drug trade in the United States and
if you look at drug fueled violence and
other cartel fueled violence in the
United States the cartels have killed
more Americans than just a handful of
years than the entire campaigns in Iraq
Afghanistan and all domestic terrorism
since 9/11 combined and yet no one wants
to talk about the Mexican drug cartels
and we're all talking about you know
Islamic terrorists in the Middle East
who can't really effectively carry out
too many strikes here I mean it's a
threat that can be largely contained
really amazing points amazing facts
bringing them to light so people can
really think and ponder and reflect
about the sad reality now another
reality is that people have more of a
chance of being killed is that true by
lightning maybe secondhand smoke or get
this your furniture then some kind of
supposed Muslim terrorists here in
America can you comment on this yeah and
not just Muslim terrorists but if you
look at all terrorism since 9/11 you're
talking about you know even considering
when you add up the new cases in since
9/11 and you're talking about around 80
people that have been killed since 9/11
by all terrorism
regardless of its if it's Muslim white
people whatever so that that's a very
small number of people in more than
roughly a decade and a half
you know we had tens of thousands of
Americans that killed themselves that
commit suicide in this country every
year we have hundreds of thousands of
people that die in accidents every year
we have million literally more than a
million people who died as a result of
medical malpractice and preventable
diseases etc every single year in
America so I mean if people were
concerned about protecting Americans
lives and their well-being then you know
investing in things like healthcare
infrastructure psychological care of
these things would clearly be a bigger
priority than terrorism in fact even the
police just this year just in the first
half of this year had killed more than
six hundred people so the police killed
six times as many people just in the
first half of this year as terrorists
that killed since 9/11 and
decade-and-a-half terrorism is not a
major problem and Muslim terrorism is
not even a majority of the very small
problem that terrorism is to begin with
Professor Moussa tell us you also wrote
another article discussing about the
greater threat I I'm a racist uh sorry I
am devising threats of right-wing
extremism so the combined total of
far-right extremists active here in
America is in the hundreds of thousands
now compare that to Isis supporters you
know we have probably just a few
thousand of those what's the answer well
the answer is we are desperately in need
of more resources here in America to
combat this problem I can personally say
that we have hundreds of analysts in the
US government looking at al Qaeda and
Isis and their affiliates but we have
mere dozens of analysts looking at non
Islamic extremists here in America
that's coming from the domestic
terrorists here
who have nothing to do with Islam or
being a Muslim so again it's important
to underscore that the the supposed
threat of terrorism is overstated and
that by making terrorism such a big deal
that's actually what gives terrorists
power and that's actually what
encourages people to carry out terrorist
attacks so in a large part we sort of
playing into the hands that we're
creating an atmosphere where terrorism
becomes more appealing by the way we
react to terrorism but again with
regards to how terrorism shakes out it's
almost always native-born white men so
right now it's the right wing that's
that's carrying out most of the attacks
but previously like during the Cold War
it was mostly like this but but still
that was native-born you know white men
but right currently post 9/11 the terror
threat has been overwhelmingly from the
right the left wing terrorism is pretty
much stopped in America right now so
it's it's mostly right wing terrorism
we're gonna go ahead and take a break
right back with more with Professor Musa
don't go anywhere
please subscribe to the video follow us
on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show with Professor Moses
Moosa and you've covered the 60,000 plus
people a lot of it decapitations people
being eaten alive right next to our
borders no wall-to-wall coverage you
also we discussed the Robert Duggar
plan to Massacre a whole entire
community gets all basically what a slap
on the wrist
no wall-to-wall coverage and then you
have the domestic threat here of
terrorism nothing to do with Muslims or
Islam you have more of a chance of being
killed by your furniture then you do
some kind of
Muslim extremists but again Muslim blows
a firecracker and it's wall-to-wall
coverage and this fear and hysteria
boogeyman type of movie drama is coming
to get you from Islam people are all
scared because Isis 24/7 it's gonna come
knocking on your door is this some kind
of hidden agenda here it's kind of
obvious is this hypocrisy what do you
think yeah so so you raised a good point
here on that one sort of tease out a
little bit and then I'll get to the main
question but you mentioned how like
right-wing people when they commit
terror attacks no one no one asks the
right to condemn terror to condemn the
attacks to disassociate from these
people in fact we never even discussed
the fact that a lot of these crimes are
committed by people impelled by the same
kind of ideology there's a there's a
worldview that impels this terrorism and
it same is true with the cartels
actually so usually when people try to
explain the difference of how they treat
Muslims versus everyone else they say
well the difference is that is Islam and
Muslims are a sort of unified by a
certain ideology to carry out these
attacks and and that's problematic
I mean it's problematic because a lot of
the ideological views that they ascribe
to Isis obviously most Muslims don't
subscribe to them but even a lot of Isis
people don't subscribe to them they join
Isis for a number of reasons and
probably a lot of them actually most of
them that are from Iraq and Syria aren't
joining because they agree that the
cause because there's economic pressures
and social pressures kristensen robohelp
Syria Isis is pretty much the only game
in town if you want to be able to feed
your family or you know stay stable or
whatever so a lot of people are sort of
affiliated with Isis for those kinds of
reasons not because they're sort of
hardcore jihadis but we never talk about
the ideological underpinnings of the
drug cartels
talk about the ideological underpinnings
of these right-wing terrorists even
though that is largely what motivates
the violence in these cases and it's
important to confront those ideologies
and it's really disturbing because a lot
of right-wing people actually sympathize
when so so when someone like Dylan roof
commits this church shooting in the name
of the Confederacy a lot of people
sympathize with this whole idea that
America is being taken away by
minorities and we need to assert our
white rights and we're in the middle of
some kind of cultural work you know so
many Americans actually sympathize with
this and not just in America but you
know around the world perhaps millions
of people in Europe and ándale ándale
essence and in fact the right-wing
ideologues are the primary targets in
Europe as well it's the same ideology
and it's never confronted and until you
confront it you know it's gonna keep it
that's what enables it to continue and
then our irony is that the very people
who are committing for who are
responsible for most terror acts and the
US and Europe these right-wing
ideologues are the people who are
championing the anti-muslim fervor and
in these same countries and you know
that's largely a deflection but from
their own sort of crazy but you know
then there are other incentives so if
you're a media company and you're trying
to decide how to cover terrorism Muslims
are a pretty small you know minority in
America and in Europe so if you a lien
eight then it's not a big deal per se
whereas if you're alienating people who
sympathize with right-wing ideology
that's potentially a lot of viewers
that's a lot of you know advertising
revenue that you potentially lose fine
and then you know on top of that you
have to face possibly massive you know
social media and other retaliation even
lawsuits so yeah what do you when you
vote the right yeah they hit you back
and I have experienced this myself
actually I've been the face of a number
of smear campaigns by Fox News and
Breitbart and other right-wing groups
accusing me of being a terrorist
sympathizer simply because I call out
these kinds of you know disparities so
it's tough it's tough to actually
confront this because in order to really
confront this ideology it can't just be
Muslims and it can't just be minorities
that are calling this out other white
people especially Republicans need to be
the ones condemning this challenging
these views and that's not happening but
they're protecting these streets another
interesting point is that the supposed
experts that come on to talk about Islam
and Muslims they have more in common
with this fringe element Isis that
obviously doesn't represent Islam but
the majority of the Muslim scholars in
the Muslim world and more Muslims are
actually dying and being killed by this
fringe element but the people who have
more in common with Isis and the extreme
element are the people who are the
so-called export non-muslim experts who
interpret Islam is such a crazy and
extreme way and and leave off the real
scholarship and the real people who are
out there advocating for peace and
understanding and so they shun them off
you don't get to hear them in the main
media press but they go ahead and find
the worst of the worst to put them up
high and give him the microphone do you
see this contradiction the right-wing
extremists and the sort of Isis
extremists actually reinforced one
another and I find you can literally see
them doing this so for instance after
the when Pamela get out there had that
drama homemade contests
and then these two people tried to
commit a you know commit a shooting or a
massacre there they failed didn't killed
or injured anyone they they died in the
process but again this is another case
with the media though made a huge deal
about it and if you tune in to Fox News
in the aftermath of that they had Pamela
Geller on defending her acts and the
person that she was talking to on the
other side Fox presented as a Muslim
cleric but it was actually Angela Dottie
who is Isis's number-one propagandist in
the UK and he's very upfront about this
this is why he is he's an isis
propagandists and they had him debating
pamela geller on fox but they didn't
disclose the fact that Angela dari
is is an Isis propagandist they just
presented him as a Muslim cleric so
people who watched Fox her who's already
talking about how Pamela Geller should
be stoned and stuff like this
and they thought oh this is what Muslims
think this is how Muslims feel because
they go out of their way to find the
most extreme people to sort of put side
by side with someone like Geller - for
the sake of misrepresenting because they
want you know these two extremes just
feeding on one another and perpetuating
the conflict it really seems like the
KKK who was at 1.5 million plus member
strong in America they didn't go away it
just didn't seem like the cool thing to
where the the white folks that they were
wearing but now that mentality that race
is bigoted I'm white I'm right and
everything else we need to get out of
sight
that mentality now they just maybe it's
still there but they put on the nice
suits and they got the air it's really
sad to see really sad what so what
advice do you have for the sincere
Americans were out there more bigoted
who aren't racists who want to live in
peace with their with their neighbors
and that's what Muslims want to do we
want to live in peace have peace with
our Creator peace within ourselves and
peace with humanity but now for them to
see through all of this confusion what
advice do you have one
is just listen to actual Muslims you
know a you can't there's all of these
experts post 9/11 that are not Muslims
talking about what Muslims non-muslims
feel and a lot of them are crap you know
and some of them are motivated by
various you know financial and other
things to intentionally misrepresent
things in a certain way um yeah it's the
Serbian for instance if you watch CNN
and they're talking about terrorism and
it's a whole panel of fifty year old
white man you know talking about Islam
and Islamic ideology you should probably
take that with a grain of salt but
that's the norm so you know when you're
confronted with this sort of a view
what you should try to do is find an
alternative viewpoint by listening to
actual Muslims and trying to get a
diverse array of Muslims because you
know Muslims are not at marlott any more
than blacks or anyone else we have
diverse viewpoints we disagree about
stuff and people need to be aware of
that may need to dig in there and try to
get it more than once you once you know
a grasp of how Muslims feel if they're
concerned about a song but if you want
to know more about song professor Moses
Moosa tell us where people can go ahead
and read some of your articles that
we've discussed today with you and how
they can get a hold of you
so my website is Fiat Sophia a
dockworker so fi eighty SOP HIA
where I you know I run system at work as
well I'm just leased them to my work and
my website there so thank you professor
we started with peace we I'm with peace
we look forward to having you sometime
in the future back on the show god bless
you jazakallah Haider Salaam alaikum
peace be with you and thank you the
sincere viewer the sincere person with
an open mind open heart who really wants
to know look he's coming to the Muslims
to find out what's Islam got to say
about this what do Muslims have to say
and now you've heard our voice now you
decide we got we had a lot of ground
that we covered in a short amount of
time we talked about the double standard
we had the sad tragic events
that happened at Charleston and
Chattanooga and one were considered a
lone wolf but now other people are
trying to hang and go to war with a snob
because some person went and did a lone
wolf act and now you trying to blame a
whole religion so are you part of the
problem or you want to be a part of the
solution and we talked about Robert
Duggar
who's all of a sudden his name just got
swept under the rug you don't know about
him and this individual who was a
minister Christian minister now do we
blame Christianity and Christians for
this crazy deluded person's plot and
plan to Massacre a whole entire
community of Muslims and you know by now
by watching today so a Muslim is like
what Jesus was because Jesus was a
Muslim and Abraham was a Muslim and
Moses was a Muslim they are what
submitted to the will of God this is
what Muslim is one who's figured out the
purpose of life and that purpose of life
is what to connect with the one who made
life who gave us life and we love Jesus
and His Blessed Mother and you get to
learn those things in previous shows so
now he wanted to murder all these people
that love Jesus and he got a smack on
the wrist
no wall-to-wall media coverage jame home
Hollins who was also the movie Massacre
he was looked at as a lone wolf but he
was also a Christian you also have
Andrew Brevik who killed over 77 people
and why do I mention these people
because now many people are assuming
that Islam is the problem but no you
don't see Muslims doing the majority of
these horrific acts you don't see that
but it's made to appear so to the
average layman that yes Muslims and
Islam is the problem but I'm sorry it's
not spend some time with the Muslims
learn Islam from the scholars here in
America who are out there
and their voices are not being heard but
they've got a strong presence in the
Muslim community talk to them invite
them to be on fox news invite them to be
on CNN if you really want to be a part
of the solution and not the problem
and that's what it seems like many
people are part of their just anger and
bitter because when we look at the root
cause of all this it's that racism and
hatred that was with the KKK but now
it's still in the hearts of the people
it hasn't been eradicated it just put on
a new costume it just has a new
appearance
so as the KKK we can spot them really
loud and clear many of these people now
we can spot them by the false fear
rhetoric the bigotry that comes out of
their mouths so let's not listen to
people such as this who are trying to
disunite humanity let's really support
and look towards creating an environment
of peace and understanding and if you
have any questions or concerns please
call us
[Music]